because it's a day that ends in Y
socialist congresswoman Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez is spreading lies
specifically about the crisis on our
southern border we will separate fact
from fiction which will leave a
unrestricted then quility deter and eNOS
speaks out after his brutal beating at
the hands of an Tifa finally Nike disses
the flag for the 4th of July so the
Governor of Arizona disses Nike all that
and more I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the sky is blue the Sun is bright and
AOC is spreading lies surprising
surprising I know
AOC took another trip down to get some
photo ops at the southern border and she
is now telling the press and all of her
Twitter followers that the Border Patrol
agents there though you know the ones
working in the concentration camps
that's what she's calling the detention
centers so if their concentration camps
and the Border Patrol agents have to be
Nazis I guess and so she's describing
them as psychologically abusing the
prisoners of harming them of conducting
psychological warfare and of making the
detainees the illegal aliens who were
there drink toilet water if they want to
hydrate themselves here's AOC and they
put them in group with no running water
and these women were being told by CBP
officers to drink out of the toilet they
were drinking water out of the toilet
and that was them knowing that a
congressional visit was coming that was
this is CBP on their best behavior
telling people to drink out of the
toilet
so you hear that at the end you hear the
reporters say did you see someone
actually do that when she's talking
about how the Border Patrol wants the
illegal aliens to drink out of the
toilet did you see someone actually do
that the window goes up she don't want
to answer that question because of
course you didn't see anybody actually
do that so what she just said is not
true there's no evidence for what she's
saying and there's a lot of evidence to
the contrary because border patrol
immediately started releasing images of
what their facilities look like and as
always with the left there is almost a
hair of a semblance of a grain of truth
in what they're saying and then they use
that almost tiny iota of a grain of
truth to be twisted into a lie so you
can see from this photo they released
what they have in these facilities is
toilets that are connected to sinks and
out of the sinks is
notable water drinking water they don't
have potable water in the toilet bowls
obviously that's toilet water but there
is a sink connected to the toilet this
is true as they pointed out of every
municipal jail in the country and though
the Border Patrol official said quote of
course that's what we have no-one is
drinking toilet water they're drinking
potable water from the sink attached to
the toilet it's what you would find in
every municipal jail in the United
States now I think is connected to the
toilet then I I guess you can almost
plausibly say with a straight face
they're telling people to drink from the
toilet but they're not telling them to
drink toilet water
they're telling them to drink from an
instrument that is connected to the
toilet so why would she make these
claims when it's so easily disproven you
look at the picture you say oh okay so
she it's like the worst kind of
clickbait Border Patrol tells aliens to
drink out of toilet connected sink that
has perfectly fine drinking water coming
out of it so you know you click on that
headline you're so shocked by and then
you realize the reality is perfectly
fine why would she do it one is she is
genuinely unintelligent she actually is
she's savvy she's got a certain
cleverness she's shrewd but she really
is unintelligent and uneducated and so I
guess it's plausible to give her the
benefit of the doubt that she even saw
one of these instruments or she heard
about it secondhand and just didn't
realize what was going on that I guess
is plausible however I think there's a
more obvious answer here and it's why
it's such a good attack we'll get to
that in a second but first let me tell
you how to make your neighborhood safer
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer now you might already know about
their smart video doorbells and cameras
that protect millions of people
everywhere because I tell you about them
all the time and more important even
than protecting you and being really
efficient at keeping your family safe
they just make you feel really cool
because you can talk to anybody who
comes to visit
you've got your you've got a guy trying
to break in or you've got a guy
delivering a package or you've got your
mother-in-law stopping by and you can
see them you can stay connected
to your home you can talk to them
two-way audio from anywhere in the world
so you can be in your bedroom or you can
be on a beach if there is anybody coming
to your house you can deal with them and
that is thanks to the HD video and to
wait audio features on ring devices or
senior producer Jay hey I mean this is
one of the great stories of ring he's
lying in his bed next to his lovely wife
it's 3:00 in the morning and his
doorbell goes off and it's these
whacked-out druggies who his house is
kind of hard to get to
they didn't just accidentally stumble on
his house they were there casing the
joint they figure maybe no one's home
and he responds he goes excuse me what
do you want what are you here for
they're shocked they didn't expect to
hear a voice on the other end they
scared scatter away they run away now
what had happened what would have
happened if he didn't answer that
doorbell if he wasn't able to talk to
them if he wasn't at home I don't know
maybe they break a window maybe they
robbed him who knows right now is a
listener you have a special offer on a
ring starter kit you can feel as safe as
I do not only just ring make me feel
safe personally but I give it away to
all of my friends when they buy a new
house it's it's that good with a video
doorbell motion activated floodlight
camera the starter kit has everything
you need to start building a ring of
security around your home the way you do
that is go to ring accom slash knowles
canada wles that is ring comm slash
Knolls be safe protect your family and
feel extremely cool and futuristic while
you do it so why would a OC make these
obviously ridiculous claims I think the
real reason she went down there to do
this is she needs new border photos and
new border stories to get the last
obviously staged one out of the news so
do you saw this within the last week or
two those photos came out of AOC
visiting the border a while ago and she
was wearing all white she was also
wearing an $800 watch on her wrist watch
on her wrist this Gucci watch so she's
wearing that but you know she kind of
wished that wasn't there for the cameras
and she's got this ridiculous acting
going on she's sort of crying with her
arm up over her eyes bent over
then you know she stood up had to
readjust for the light or something like
that
and there's that really serious photo of
her looking into the camera she's really
there's no tears anywhere of course cuz
it's just all play-acting but she was
staging all of them and this became a
meme and we all made fun of her so then
a week later just coincidentally she
goes down to the border to get these new
photos and the only way to really make
this stick is to make insane claims and
this is what a OC does she makes insane
outrageous claims and we all start
talking about it and the right points
out that what she's saying just is
simply not true and then the left as if
by reflex has to oppose what the right
is saying and so the left starts to say
well actually she's sort of right even
though she isn't so you see this playing
out now with the that you saw it with
the green new deal for instance she said
the world is going to end in 12 years
unless we pass a 93 trillion dollar
program that gets rid of cars train some
most trains or airplanes cows every
building in the country unless we do
that there's no way that we can possibly
stave off this natural Armageddon and so
conservatives pointed out that that
isn't true the world isn't going to end
in 12 years and then the left came and
said well no but actually actually
though which she meant is that in 12
years the damage will be so bad that
it'll be really super hard to combat it
so really you know she's right sort of
or something and that's what they're
doing here so she says Border Patrol is
making women drink out of toilet bowls
and that's not happening there's no
evidence that that's happening so the
right point said add and then the less
says well but actually the sinks are
attached to the toilets so like really
you know when you really think about it
actually she's right
and then she benefits from this because
she's in the news the whole time from
the minute she says the stupid thing and
then the right starts talking about her
she dominates the news cycle then the
left tries to defend her not because
they like her they don't like her
there's a rumor in New York that they're
gonna try to get rid of her
congressional district in 2022 because
she causes so much trouble for them but
they have to defend her because they
hate the right so much
so then they defend her she gets a whole
nother cycle adamant meanwhile now we
forget about her stupid photos at the
border from last week now we get these
new photos now we get these new claims
you know President Trump in some way had
used this strategy except the difference
of course being that president Trump
would say some outlandish thing and then
it would seem to be proven correct so he
would say illegal aliens are killing
people all over the country it's say oh
that's that's hyperbolic that's not
really happening then you have the death
of Katie Steinle it's very high-profile
killing from an illegal alien you say oh
I guess he guess he was onto something
Trump will say we're gonna use tariffs
to get a new trade deal and immigration
deal with Mexico say oh that's it's
never gonna work tariffs don't work
there's no way you know and then the
left would go crazy and it turns out it
actually did work so you know there's a
little bit of this strategy with Trump I
just think more often than not with
Trump it turns out that the claim he was
making is largely true with aoc that
doesn't happen that I don't think that's
ever happened and so so she really gets
a lot of benefits out of this now how do
we know that the conditions are actually
not that bad on the border first of all
because we've got other people who are
going in there and telling us that
they're not that bad a Washington
Examiner reporter tweeted out that two
sources inside the building inside this
border patrol facility said that AOC
didn't even tour one of the facilities
that she was tweeting about wasn't even
inside why else do we know that she's
not telling the truth because she
wouldn't clarify whether she actually
heard the toilet thing herself firsthand
or whether she just heard a rumor about
it second hand or third hand she's been
asked by media outlets to clarify she
won't clarify the third way that we know
that she is not telling the truth about
this and this is the best one of all if
the detention centers were really these
concentration camp filled with torture
awful abusive places probably over 3,000
a legal aliens per day wouldn't be
flooding across our border right if
these were really awful
torturous camps we wouldn't be seeing an
increase in illegal immigration
I mean 3,000 a day right now is the low
estimate if it was that bad people would
just not break the law and they would
just stay in their own countries or at
the very least let's say they're fleeing
El Salvador they're fleeing Honduras
they're wherever they would at least
stay in Mexico they wouldn't stay they
wouldn't go into the United States if it
were really as bad as IOC is saying it
is but it's not
we're just detaining illegal aliens
because they're breaking the law and
we're trying to do the best that we can
to deal with them well discouraging more
from coming over but this gives away the
whole game because if Democrats actually
wanted to stop this abuse that's what
they would do they would discourage
people from crossing the border
illegally and is that what they're doing
no actually instead they're doing
everything they can to incentivize more
and more people to cross that border
illegally who Leon Castro running for
president right now as a Democrat came
out and said that he wants to
decriminalize illegal border crossings
here he is I'm not buying into the BS
that basically says that little children
and mothers who are desperate and
fleeing desperate circumstances are a
national security threat to our nation I
said that we should decriminalize people
who are coming here crossing the border
okay first of all nobody ever said that
mothers and children are the national
security threat what we said is that an
open border is the national security
threat we know that this is true
Nicaragua just days ago arrested for
Isis terrorists who were entering at
Nicaragua were trying to get in there
and then cross the u.s. southern border
illegally that is a national security
threat but who Leon Castro can't make
serious arguments so he just has to try
to burn down straw men but who Leon
Castro is unwilling to admit all the
Democrats are unwilling to admit a very
simple fact which is that when you
decriminalize something you get more of
it you are incentivizing it but they're
doing something even worse to
incentivize illegal border crossing
something even more heinous we'll get to
that in a second but first if you don't
know your numbers you don't
your business and the problem growing
businesses have here is that they they
just have too many systems so it keeps
them from knowing their numbers they've
got this hodgepodge of business systems
because it's easier to just start out
with this one system here and then okay
we got to add some new accounting
software we're gonna go here and this is
where NetSuite comes in handy
NetSuite by Oracle is the business
management software that handles every
aspect of your business in an
easy-to-use platform on the cloud which
gives you visibility and it gives you
the control that you need to grow I've
been involved in a lot of companies
including this one when if they were
just starting up and people do this all
the time they you know you're running
you're doing 10 million jobs when you're
starting a business so you just have a
ton of inefficiencies and over time
those inefficiencies cost you time they
cost you money they cause you a lot of
unneeded headaches we'll fix that now
when you want to move to the next level
you've got to fix that
by managing sales by managing finances
by managing accounting orders an HR
instantly you can do all of that right
from your desktop or phone with NetSuite
that's why it's the world's number one
cloud business system I wish and the
businesses that I've been involved in
helping to start up and involved in from
early stages I wish we'd taken the
moments that were just from the very
beginning and say we're gonna bring this
all together right now from the very
beginning because it just it creates a
lot of aggravation creates a lot of
hassle later on I always wish you could
do that sometimes it's not possible to
do it very early it's not possible to
have that foresight no reason not to do
it right now because NetSuite is
offering you valuable insights with a
free guide seven key strategies to grow
your profits at NetSuite calm slash
Knowles candor wles that's NetSuite comm
slash Knowles canna wles to download
your free it guides seven key strategies
to grow your profits check it out you
won't regret it
NetSuite comm slash Knowles so the other
way that they are on the Left
incentivizing people to pour into this
country illegally incentivizing this
major exacerbation of the problem at the
border is by calling for open borders
for family
units specifically right this has been
sort of their de-facto position for
years we're told you can't detain
children this is this began during the
Clinton administration during the Flores
agreement in 1997 they say you can't
detain children in jails fair enough I
yeah when no one wants to put children
in jails but if the children are there
with their parents or they're there with
some other adult then you've got to put
the adult in the jail or some kind of
holding facility they are breaking the
law you can't just let him go so you've
got the parents in the jail were you
gonna put the kids that you can put the
kids in an HHS facility but then you're
separating children from their parents
okay so you got to do that but then
we're told we can't separate children
from their parents so you can't put the
kids in the jail you can't separate the
children from your parents there's only
one other option what is it just let
them go which is the left position that
the left's position is okay maybe we can
detain you if you're a single guy and
you're how many kids with you but we're
not going to detain you if you have any
kids with you so guess what that does it
incentivizes people to bring a kid with
them doesn't matter if it's their kid
doesn't matter where they get the kid
they have a kid with them it makes it
much easier to cross so now Mexico is
confirming what we already knew State
Department has already been talking
about this and and Mexico is now
confirming it men are offering to buy
children in Mexico to cross the border
illegally this is the result of these
policies you know the left wants to
pretend that letting illegal aliens that
have kids go roam free is compassionate
they want to pretend that a totally open
border is compassionate
well this is what that compassion gets
you it gets you roving bands of men
going to orphanages and going to
desperate women in Mexico and offering
to purchase their children there is a
Honduran woman in Mexico she was
interviewed she said quote I can't go to
work because I can't take my eyes off my
boys she said that men offered her $350
to buy children at the Iglesia
ambassadora sneha zeus shelter in
Tijuana
Tijuana's pretty close it's not that far
from where I am right now
she said they want to rob our kids so
they can cross into the United States
the people who are doing this by the way
are not refugees they're not desperate
refugees fleeing violence for the vast
majority of illegal aliens pouring into
our country their economic migrants who
just want better jobs and want to make
more money fair enough if I lived in El
Salvador I would want that too that's
not an argument for completely violating
the laws of a sovereign country
violating national borders violating the
people of America's right to
self-government that's not an argument
for that if they were really just
fleeing political violence they could
stay in any of the countries they
stopped in along the way that's where
this Honduran woman was she was staying
in Mexico and on their way to cross into
the US illegally
a group of men tried to buy her children
for $350 each you know with the left
it's all crocodile tears until you
actually do something about it AOC can
go down to the border wearing as many
Gucci watches as she wants and pretend
to cry she's covering her eyes so that
you can't see that she's not actually
crying and talk about how awful it is
and make up a bunch of lies about border
control but it's just words words words
leftist policies have created this
crisis at the border and now the left is
blaming conservatives for the crisis and
they're saying the only way to fix the
crisis is with more leftist policies
which created the problem in the first
place
the left is getting it as always exactly
backwards that's not just at the border
you saw this moving all the way over to
Portland you saw this over the weekend
at that antifa thuggery that went on in
the streets of Portland you saw it when
an Tifa is beating and II know when they
were beating this quill atena taranti
node you know what they were chanting
they were chanting no hate no fear as
they were cracking this guy's skull and
they were giving him a brain hemorrhage
well and Ino is finally speaking out
here he is on Tucker last night while
hearing people chant no hate no fear I'm
suddenly bashed on the back of my head
from behind and from there I've I'm a
very positive person I've never been in
a fight it took me a few seconds to
realize that I was actually even hit in
my head and you can see on Andy now he's
got a shiner he's got a black eye he's
got some other scrapes and bruises on
his face obviously you can't see what's
going on in the back of his head and I
first of all you I mean you can hear
these sort of things in the video but
I've seen the left do this myself I've
seen it firsthand you know when I was
fortunately much less injured than Andy
was when I was at the University of
missouri-kansas city
and I was giving a speech called men are
not women and some masked and Tifa
lunatic busted in and sprayed me with
some weird combination of luckily
non-toxic chemicals he immediately gets
tackled by the police so he busts in
with this super soaker kind of gun he
gets a spray off of whatever creepy
liquid he had on him and he sprays it at
me shoots it at me he goes down the cops
are arresting him and the leftist
activists out there started chanting
hands up don't shoot I wish they had
chanted it at their leftist comrade when
he busted in then I might still have my
suit before he got it sprayed with
whatever weird paint glitter stuff he
had he literally came in with a type of
gun and shot it then he's being arrested
no guns
anywhere and they say hands up don't
shoot to the guys who don't have guns
who are just arresting him and stopping
the guy who does have a giant squirt gun
completely backwards so what what
happened to Andy he puts it in his own
words when I realized what was happening
it was too late
a mob of people all dressed in black and
wearing masks started beating me with
their fists and some of them use objects
to hit me I don't know how many people
were involved it seems like 5 10 15 or
20 it could have been that many they
beat me so much that I lost control of
my GoPro camera that I was holding which
was then stolen from me
and when I thought it was over I was
wrong I put my arms up to try to shield
my face as well as to signal to them
that I was surrendering and that I
wasn't there to fight without really
signaled to them to be more aggressive
so then they started dumping what I
believe were milkshakes and eggs
throwing it out my face which blinded me
so I couldn't see and I was kicked some
more punched some more and all this time
I kept thinking we're the police I could
still see the Mahnomen County Justice
Center in front of me but no police have
arrived that's the question
where were the police where were they we
see them in a couple videos later and
Andy says to them where were you I was
attacked twice before you guys even sort
of showed up one or two you show up
where were they why why weren't they
there it seems to me pretty clear
someone told them that they didn't have
to police this event or they didn't have
to police it very meticulously so the
question then isn't just where the
police that's where were the politicians
what were the politicians telling them
to do why were the politicians like the
mayor of this town basically handing it
over to an Tifa I mean this isn't just a
joke you got sprayed with silly string
you know some guy poured a milkshake on
him okay I mean that's awful that is a
physical assault that took place but
they're also cracking his head they're
also blinding him with eggs in his eyes
they also caused his brain to bleed
he tells what happened I eventually
stumbled away bleeding across the park
and I lost my balance so I sat down on
the ground in front of the courthouse
and from there a medic SWAT team informs
me that in order to get an ambulance to
be taken to a hospital I would have to
walk to the police precinct in other
words walk back in the direction of the
demonstrators who just attacked me
later that night after
arriving in the emergency room I had a
CT scan which confirmed that there that
I was diagnosed with a brain hemorrhage
so he's got a brain hemorrhage his brain
is bleeding and he's told when the cops
finally show up they say oh yeah if you
want to get an ambulance you got to walk
back through and Tifa the guys that just
cracked your head and and threw eggs on
your face and punched you and gave you
all those marks on your face gave you a
shiner you gotta walk through them and
then we'll have an ambulance picked you
up there what are the consequences for
this who is gonna pay a price well
finally the mayor of Portland
Ted wheeler he gives his answer he
explains what's happening he says what's
going to happen and it is the most
cowardly mealy-mouthed despicable answer
to leftist violence that I have seen in
the entire country we'll break it down
in a second then we have to get to Nikes
big diss on the American flag and a
wonderful political response to that
we'll try to get to a little bit more if
we have time but first I've got a second
bite of Facebook and YouTube go to daily
wire calm 10 bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership what do you get what
don't you get you get me you get the
Andrew Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Ben Shapiro
radio show and by the way I'm going to
be sitting in for that today so you will
get three more hours of me can you
imagine it's like we're going on a date
or something I mean that's a long time
so you'll get all of that you get the
Matt Walsh show you test questions in
the mailbag coming up on Thursday
actually today on Ben's radio show
you'll also get an interview that I'm
doing with Andy no he's going to come on
hasn't talked to too many people yet
about what happened to him so we'll
discuss that later on today you get
everything and you get the leftist tears
tumblr mmm ooh that tastes like the
Governor of Arizona smacking down Nike
for dissing the American flag on the 4th
of July we will explain it all just
after this go to daily wire comm we'll
be right back
you know I just remembered we're not
gonna have a mailbag on Thursday because
it's going to be the fourth of July and
so I guess on Thursday you will write
your questions to America just address
them to America and then you know hand
them out on the fourth of July and every
answer will be just a very beautiful
American firework exploding if only
that's how I feel when I'm giving
answers in the mailbag I feel like
they're all just fireworks so we'll do
that unfortunately nothing so we'll have
to do double mailbag next week or
something like that the mayor of
Portland
finally issues a statement about what
happened about aunty FFA's attack on
Andino and other people
cracking their skulls sending them to
the hospital with brain hemorrhages does
he call out an Tifa as the domestic
terrorist group that they are no does he
take responsibility for his complete
failure as mayor and for the failure of
the police no does he smear the
right-wingers as basically deserving
their attacks as asking for it yes of
course he does that because he's a
leftist so here's what he wrote quote
Portland has always been a beacon of
free speech we're proud of that history
but see and there it is
you knew the butt was coming the minute
he talked about how much he likes free
speech you saw the butt was coming and
so he a Butthead says we're proud of
that history of free speech but in the
last couple of years some have
increasingly used their opportunity to
exercise their First Amendment rights as
an opportunity to incite violence there
it is he goes on for about ten other
tweets that told you everything you need
to know he's saying that the
Conservatives who got their skulls
cracked open by leftist terrorists over
the weekend they were asking for it
because they incited violence he can
only be referring to the white
right-wingers they come out there was a
patriot prayer rally so they're out
demonstrating for patriotism and prayers
two things I like very much and
that's that's them exercising their
First Amendment rights then a bunch of
leftist terrorists staged a premeditated
attack and crack their skulls open and
what I just described is what happened
the way mayor wheeler describes that is
some people irresponsibly used their
First Amendment rights to incite
violence I mean it was incited and Tifa
couldn't do anything about that it was
they got incited you can't incite
somebody and then not expect them to
crack your skull open right I mean you
were wearing an awful short skirt and II
know what were you doing walking down
that street at night in that short skirt
you mean come on you telling me you're
telling me you weren't asking to have
that head cracked open you telling me
you weren't asking for a brain
hemorrhage that's what Ted wheeler is
saying in Portland he goes on over the
weekend some chose to engage in violence
in Portland which is unacceptable and
not to be tolerated we stand against all
forms of violence regardless of
someone's political leanings so right
he's even assuming that there's a
question that you wouldn't stand against
some forms of violence if you disagreed
with that person's politics that's
actually the assumption is saying we
wouldn't do that even if even if they're
conservatives we would never do that we
it won't be tolerated we stand against
it of course we won't do anything to
stop it and we'll have the cops stand
down and we won't even get you an
ambulance we'll make you walk back
through an Tifa to get an ambulance but
you know we totally stand against it but
but he goes on Portland police officers
have the unenviable task of keeping the
peace it's a difficult job and hard
decisions are made in real time what
hard decisions like don't help the
Conservatives who are getting their
heads cracked in that said that doesn't
sound by the way like a police decision
that sounds like a political decision
that sounds like a decision that
ultimately lays at the feet of the
mayor's office well we continue to learn
more about what transpired over the
weekend we will keep you informed we
will do everything we can to make sure
that those who have committed violence
are held accountable
sure you will you're not even holding
them accountable in your statement in
your tweet you're not holding them
accountable you're blaming the
Conservatives for inciting violence
by abusing their First Amendment rights
that was the first thing you said and
then all of the rest of it was
mealy-mouthed nonsense you know that
this is the the real example of the very
fine people on both sides argument in
Charlottesville the left never let Trump
hear the end of it when he said that
there were fine people on both sides
even though Trump went on specifically
the same paragraph to say I'm not
talking about neo-nazis I'm not talking
about white supremacists they should be
condemned
totally but the left never let him hear
the end of it but now wheeler is saying
there were good people on both sides we
will stand against all forms of violence
regardless of someone's political
feelings some chose to gay to engage in
violence no some didn't choose antifa
chose the left chose many defense the
police if you want to hold people
accountable
mayor wheeler named them you can't hold
anyone accountable unless you name them
unless we know who they are they can't
be held accountable their name is an
Tifa that's their name they're a
domestic terrorist organization they
meet the very basic definition of
terrorism they use violence against
civilians to achieve political goals
they are terrorists if they are not
terrorists no one is a terrorist but he
won't name them because he's not gonna
hold him accountable because he doesn't
really think they did anything wrong
because they were incited to violence by
those awful conservatives and this is by
the way what authoritarian politicians
have done for all of history people
think authoritarians are idiots
Mussolini these people that Mussolini
founded fascism right they think that
Mussolini is a total idiot
that he would he would own every aspect
of the fascist agenda he didn't there
were there were always in these regimes
paramilitary organizations so you've had
it in the United States in the United
States when the Democratic Party after
the Civil War was oppressing black
Americans recently freed slaves
instituting Jim Crow instituting
lynchings removing the
Civil Rights when they were doing that
they didn't only do it under the guise
of the Democratic Party they did it from
the paramilitary wing of the Democratic
Party which was called the Ku Klux Klan
the fascists had a paramilitary wing the
kamichan had a the Blackshirts the
Maoists in china had a pair of military
wing they were the Red Guard there and
there was a little bit of a difference
there was a little bit of a separation
from the government itself from the
regime itself and the radical left has a
paramilitary wing and that's an Tifa and
so what they're saying is oh that's very
bad tisk tisk antia they slapped them on
the wrists you really shouldn't do that
of course you were incited and a really
a smart conservative wouldn't open their
mouth and invite that sort of brutality
but bad bad don't do that again unless
those conservatives act up again
that's what's happening that's what's
being encouraged by politicians like Ted
wheeler absolutely disgraceful obviously
he should resign he won't resign
obviously he should be made to resign he
won't be I suspect because the
electorate in Portland is very far left
but that guy with that statement that
guy is complicit in whatever future
violence occurs up there totally
switching gears in some good political
news we got bad news out of corporate
America we learned yesterday that Nike
was scrapping plans for a new shoe for
the 4th of July that featured the Betsy
Ross flag on it we have the Betsy Ross
flag right behind us on set it's that
early American flag you know with the
with the circle and the Stars and why is
Nike scrapping this shoe colin
kaepernick of course their spokesman the
guy calling the shots Colin Kaepernick
is now saying that the Betsy Ross flag
one of the earliest American flags is
offensive how is it's not and we're not
talking about the Stars and Bars right
we're not talking about the Confederate
flag we're talking about the Betsy Ross
flag one of the earliest flags in the
country why is it offensive because it
was flown during slave times so now we
can't have it we got a ban that flag now
of course this doesn't make any sense
how about even the current American flag
even the American flag that we have
today with all
these stars that flag flew over a
segregated country a racially segregated
country how can we possibly fly that
flag with such a major injustice
tolerated under that banner the current
America American flag 50 stars flew over
a country that had red lining black
people weren't permitted to move to
certain neighborhoods forget about just
our current national flag forget about
even our flag at all no national flag in
the history of the world has ever flown
over a perfect country right because
there's no perfect country there never
has been there is not presently and
there never will be because people are
fallen our our nature is imperfect our
political systems are imperfect so we
will never have a flag that ever flies
over a perfect country because we don't
ever have Berthe countries Colin
Kaepernick doesn't understand this or
maybe he does and he just wants to watch
the world burn this all comes as a bad
news out of Gallup comes out American
pride has hit an all-time low you know
we've talked in the past weeks a lot
about pride how pride is a terrible
thing how the left now is making an idol
out of pride itself their pride parades
Pride Day Pride Month and there is a
slight distinction to be made which is
that used cash I don't use the word
casually or I try not to but used
casually not emphatically pride in a
national context can be a stand-in for
piety or loyalty or affection it doesn't
necessarily just mean chauvinism or
something like that
now just 45% of Americans describe
themselves as extremely proud of their
country less than half the majority of
Americans are not extremely proud of
their country just 22% of Democrats are
extremely proud of their country
that's down 10 points in just one year
even setting aside our problems with the
word pride I think we can acknowledge
praat when you're not just making an
idol out of pride itself when you're
using it in a broader context it's a
stand-in for affection to your country
and just 22% of Democrats feel that I
called the
ten years ago this hook this whole flag
thing I called it I was a freshman in
college and my roommate and I were like
the only two conservatives at the whole
college and we had a nice big American
flag and we flew it out of our window on
old campus and this was very
controversial people asked us to take it
down they were furious that we flew an
American flag I couldn't believe it so
what's the matter with flying an
American Flitz the flag of our country
they would have felt better if I flew a
Chinese flag because that would have
been inclusive that's not inclusive
obviously it's one of the worst regimes
in the history of the world but they in
the leftist backwards world that is
inclusive because it's encouraging to
Chinese foreign exchange students or
something international students but the
American flag the best flag in the
history of the world that's the worst
one you could possibly imagine so I saw
this happening and I said it's not going
to be long before the American flag is
considered a hate symbol by the pop
culture because whatever the sort of
lefty crazy colleges are doing fast
forward ten years that's what your
culture does so that's happening now
Colin Kaepernick is trying to outlaw the
American flag trying to from a cultural
level at least ostracize and banish the
American flag as a hate symbol governor
of Arizona
Doug Ducey one of the great politicians
in this country he didn't take too
kindly to that Doug Ducey came out and
issued a statement he said quote today
was supposed to be a good day in Arizona
with the announcement of a major Nike
investment in Goodyear Arizona and then
this news broke yesterday afternoon
words cannot express my disappointment
at this terrible decision I'm
embarrassed for Nike Nike is an iconic
American brand and American company this
country our system of government and
free enterprise have allowed them to
prosper and flourish instead of
celebrating American history the week of
our nation's independence Nike has
apparently decided that Betsy Ross is
unworthy and has bowed to the current
onslaught of political correctness and
historical revisionism there's a
shameful retreat for the company
American businesses should be proud of
our country's history not abandoning it
Nike has made its decision and now we're
making ours I've ordered the Arizona
commerce authority to with
all financial incentive dollars under
their discretion that the state was
providing for the company to locate here
Arizona's economy is doing just fine
without Nike we don't need to suck up to
companies that consciously denigrate our
nation's history and finally it
shouldn't take a controversy over a shoe
for our kids to know who Betsy Ross's a
founding mother her story should be
taught in all American schools in the
meantime it's worth googling her
excellent response absolutely beautiful
totally gets it right some conservatives
don't like this response they see this
as the government unfairly picking
winners and losers that's not what's
going on at all by the way but this gets
to that low simmering debate that we've
been having between conservatives and
people who are they would call
themselves classical liberals or really
conservative liberals or something like
that the questions that come up are
should the government be picking winners
and losers and should the government be
wading into cultural questions or should
the government just provide a neutral
playing field on which we can debate
cultural questions first of all this is
not an example of the government picking
winners and losers if anything the the
government picking winners and losers
was shown when Arizona offered those
financial incentives to Nike in the
first place that was when they were
picking winners and losers what Arizona
said which is what every state does is
hey corporations if you relocate here
and you create a lot of jobs here we'll
give you a huge tax cut millions and tax
cuts billions sometimes in tax cuts if
you just come here and you're so you're
basically bribing the company to come
bring you jobs there there is no
constitutional right to state tax
incentives for corporations the state
has every right to withdraw those tax
incentives if they find out that the
corporation is denigrating the country
itself that's the first part second of
all on the cultural stuff the government
is already waiting inter-cultural
questions because it has to I think we
all agree with the patron saint of
Hollywood conservatives Andrew Breitbart
the politics is downstream of culture
but that means that politics has a huge
cultural component to it when the
government declares that sex and gender
are no longer the same as many people on
the Left want it to do that's the
government wading into culture when the
government creates a law called title 9
that protects women's sports and
colleges what is that what does the
government have to do with women's
collegiate sports you might ask well it
does it just it does have a lot to do
with that it currently does that the
government Wade's into cultural issues
when the government deems that certain
crimes are especially heinous
and deserve special punishment solely
based on the motivations of the
perpetrators that's the government
wading into cultural issues this is like
hate crime legislation which can take
crimes out of the state level make it a
federal crime just because the
perpetrator could have done the exact
same crime as anybody else but if they
can say he was motivated by some
particular view of the world some
particular bigotry or viewpoint then
it's especially punished that is the
government wading into cultural issues
this is this lie that I hear so often on
the left and the right people say you
can't legislate morality every single
law legislates morality every law when
we talk about why how we need to expand
health care coverage with a federal
program you're legislating morality when
you talk about how we need to intervene
on behalf of one country but not another
you're legislating morality when you
raise taxes in the name of fairness
you're legislating morality when you
lower taxes in the name of freedom you
are legislating morality all laws derive
ultimately at the bedrock from ethical
laws from the moral law so the question
here is will the state of Arizona reward
a country or a company rather that spits
on the American flag I am so happy that
they're not I think this governor did an
absolutely terrific job it shows that
there is some some question in the
United States beyond profit we all love
profit everyone likes making money
nobody likes making money more than I do
but
there are other things about her we're
not just simply numbers Edmund Burke you
know when he was lamenting the fall of
conservatism he said that the age of
chivalry is gone that of Sophos ters
economists and calculators has succeeded
and the glory of Europe is extinguished
forever we're not just numbers we're not
just tablets you know there was an old
view of kind of the conservative
movement in America which was just that
we were a bunch of bean counters you
know modeling what happens if we lower
taxes even more I love low taxes but
that's not yet a merely economic vision
of conservatism is a losing conservatism
why because we all agree politics is
downstream from culture if economic
views are not rooted in a cultural
conservatism a shared culture shared
premises a shared commitment to our
country to our Constitution to our
founding values to the 4th of July if
we're not grounding it in that then
we're not offering anything that's our
show we will have much more tomorrow
before we say a Jew for the 4th of July
we won't use that at French language we
won't use those people who invented
freedom fries will say goodbye for the
4th of July but we'll only do that after
tomorrow in the meantime I'm going to be
sitting in four bins radio show today so
if you want three more hours of fun come
on by in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
I'll see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka watts and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey
everyone its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show July 4th is coming
and Trump is planning a bang-up parade
but I'm wondering if that's an empty
celebration a new poll says Americans
are losing their pride in their country
are they and if they are is it too late
for them to get it back we'll talk about
it on the Andrew Clavin show on Andrew
Cleveland